thank you very much so I'm from the
University of Southampton but actually
I'm doing a sabbatical at the moment so
I'm in Hawaii which explains my shirt
and the and the slide and in Hawaii they
have this thing called Aloha Friday in
which is supposed to dress up in
Hawaiian costumes so some being um so
anyway um so I was really excited to be
at this workshop and originally I was
going to tell you one particular story
but then during the week I saw so many
talks that sort of discussed things that
I care deeply about so then I thought
okay I'm gonna need to sort of broaden
out the scope so actually the
programming relation recurrence
relations stuff is going to be probably
about 30 seconds of the talk but I'm
going to spend most of the time talking
about other compositional stuff there's
a whole bunch of people involved in this
um so some of these people you'd
recognize so disco is actually who I'm
visiting in Hawaii and well as I'll tell
you about these people as they show up
during the talk and I fortunately have a
lot of stuff to get through so I don't
really like giving these overview talks
because um you never end up saying
anything in any great detail but I'll do
my best to keep you interested but
actually there is a kind of a common
thread for this talk and it was it was
sort of explicitly identified by John
John Byers during his talk and that is
we're going to see a lot of situations
in which we're going to have two
symmetric monitor categories one which
we're going to think of is some kind of
syntax and watch and one which we're
going to think of some kind of semantics
and we're going to have going to have a
symmetric one or a functor from the
syntax to the semantics and this should
remind you of Laurie's funked oral
semantics of algebraic theories but it's
really the same spirit except we're not
going to typically be in a Cartesian
setting but in a more not all setting
right because we want to be careful
about resources in many of these
examples
and I'll tell you more or less this is
actually a chronologically correct story
so I tell you sort of what I've done in
and I know what I've learnt along the
way oh I've got a bit of clicker so
start off with talking a little bit
about Petri nets and we've already seen
some stuff about Petri Nets in John's
talk so what we're going to think about
is Petri Nets as sort of open Petri Nets
as arrows in a symmetric modal category
ok so the idea is that we have a Petri
net that looks like this which is in
this particular example this is some
kind of a token ring network ok and you
see that when you look at it as a sort
of a global monolithic net sort of when
we look at it as humans we can
immediately see that it's just you know
three identical bits wired up together
in a in a loop but you know we need an
algebra of these diagrams to bring this
out so in particular I'm going to
actually be able to write this guy as an
expression in a symmetric monocle
category excuse me which you can see I
mean it features things like like cups
and caps and identities and it has bits
which just look like Petri Nets that
sort of connect to the boundary
and I'm going to try to convince you
that this point of view is not just sort
of interesting for its own sake but it
can actually be useful so we have some
results about using this for
verification sort of compositional model
checking which came up in several talks
but also things like parametric
verification
so maybe I should start by saying
something about composition art in Petri
Nets in more generality and maybe the
history of it so composition so Petri
that's not often thought of as
compositional but actually there's been
a lot of work on looking at serve the
algebraic structure of nets and there's
sort of the way I look at it there's
really two different ways you can think
about composition out in Petri Nets so
one one way is you can think about the
computations as having some algebraic
structure okay so there's a as a
classical paper by we'll go and Joseph
Michigan Petri Nets amyloids in which
they actually considered the
computations of Petri notes as a
symmetric modal category and this are
this inspired the law of later work it
was a very influential piece of work now
the other way I see composition our teas
are carrying Petri Nets is you think of
the actual combinatorial structure of a
Petri nets as a some kind of hyper graph
and you want to split it up into
components and stick together and again
there's quite a bit of work on this I'm
just going to flash up two of these so
one of them is is this approach called
open Petri Nets which was done by Paul
about Dan and bakura Dini Hartman Terry
Rocco heckle and a number of other
people and here the idea is that we glue
together nets along places so places of
the nets are the boundaries and this
really reminds me of Blake's approach
that we saw earlier in the week but so I
guess the the interesting thing about
Blake's approach is that he considers
stochastic mass action armed semantics
and and it's really it's really
interesting it seems to be really armed
sort of a testament to the the Dutch
reality of this kind of algebra that
this is compositional right so it's
compositional respect to this stochastic
mass action semantics what I want to
talk about in a bit more detail is this
approach that I was involved in and this
idea is that we're going to glue
together nets
along transitions so just like in this
picture here you see that
here we have a single transition which
loops around and we've sort of divided
into a number of chunks here on the
right and it sort of all glues together
as as one transition and the way I think
about it actually is that sort of these
transitions that connected the
boundaries you can think of them as
synchronizations or which you have a
local view and you'll only have a global
view once you compose everything so it's
some kind of you know I'm involved in
the synchronization I know what happens
to me internally but someone else will
synchronize with me eventually and don't
be other stuff happening okay so since
we want to stay within this framework of
giving symmetric monoidal functors I'm
going to tell you about the two
categories here involved okay so so one
unfortunately ready had one category
called Petri this one I'm also going to
call Petri so this is going to be our
syntax okay and this is going to be our
semantics and the fact that this is a
symmetric model functor is where all of
the action will come in when we do
things like divide and conquer and
compositional verification okay so first
of all I'm not going to give you a
formal definition but I'll just give you
a bunch of examples of how composition
works in this category of Petri Nets
right because because I think this is
the is going to give you an intuition
for how these things work right so the
idea is that sort of errors in this
category so this is an error from zero
to two and you see we have the ability
to connect transitions to the boundaries
okay so so here for example um you know
this is a transition connected to the
boundary this is another one when I
compose they're glued together in a
single transition now you can have some
some slightly strange artifacts if you
just come from Petri net theory you
might think they're a bit they're a bit
weird so for example have a transition
that's actually not connected to
anything apart from the boundary but
what this means is essentially that this
piece here there's that there's a
synchronization that I'm willing to
participate in that just won't have any
effects on my local state right so
essentially here we can we when we
compose this just becomes a transition
that produces a token at this place
so maybe I'll just go through these very
quickly I don't want to I don't really
have time to get into the details but
you can see that some some other
interesting things can happen so so here
we have a Petri net in which we have two
separate transitions but actually I can
connect them with this strange
transition here which is connected to
both of the interface interface ports
and those two transitions that
originally we didn't know they were the
same synchronization that become the
same synchronization and that just this
just becomes a transition that consumes
a token and produces one here so here's
another interesting blue little feature
if I have a transition connected to the
boundary and I have nothing for it to
synchronize with all that transition
disappears right we need to be able to
find a partner for our synchronization
or maybe I should say one final thing
this is and this is somehow where arm
where choice can come in right so here
we have two different transitions
connected to the boundary they can both
synchronize with this guy here on the
left and the end result is you have two
synchronizations two transitions in the
result I guess I hope this I mean of
course you're not going to get the full
picture but the basic idea is that we
want to think about Petri nets as string
diagrams right and I and there's rules
on how to compose these things so that
was the syntax now what's the semantics
well if you know about this work of Bob
Walters sort of he has this thing called
the the algebra spam graph of transition
systems then you already know what the
semantics is but if you don't then I'll
just give you a very quick intuition for
what these things are so the arrows are
going to be certain transition systems
where each label each transition is
labeled with two things okay and these
two things depend depend on the boundary
okay so this is an arrow from one to one
and that means that every label will
consist of one symbol and left and one
symbol on the right okay so the idea is
that when this transition this
transition happens we can observe the
action 0 on the left boundary and the
action
on the right boundary so there's two
ways this is a symmetric moral category
so I need to tell you how to compose and
how to do the tensor products so I
compose so this is the composition of F
and G composed by it's kind of like a
product construction but I need to make
sure that I agree on this shed action on
the boundary okay so for example here I
can do a zero zero action from this
state to itself because here I can do a
zero one action and here I do a one zero
and you see I agree on this common
boundary that gets thrown away and I'm
just ended and just end up with the zero
zero action okay and so it's kind of
like an algebra of synchronization of
transition systems so what happens when
I tensor well essentially I just take
the product of transition systems and I
just concatenate the labels right
because we want to keep this intuition
that you know ten stirring is putting
boxes on top of each other so when I put
boxes on top of each other my boundary
grows okay and these things are not
connected so essentially I just take the
product of the transition systems
okay so now there's a functor that gets
me from my string diagram category
string diagram symmetric model category
of Petri Nets to this semantics okay and
that essentially tells me what the
internal states of this net sub
component are and how it interacts with
the outside world and you see that
essentially the reason for why the
alphabet is just zeros and ones is
because a transition fires that's a one
that's kind of like a signal
I'm synchronizing other labels zero
which means I don't see any any action
on the boundary okay it turns out that
this square is commutative which just
means that well it's one of the one of
the things that you need to verify to
verify that this is actually a symmetric
one of a function and this is really
where the so looking at this diagram I
can tell you I can give you some reasons
for why this is useful for verification
you see because I'm composing sort of
this big net of made out of pieces and
when I when I want to verify it this is
what I'm interested in this big you know
transition system so the idea is that if
I know about the compositional structure
if I know about how this guy is wired up
from simpler components then I can take
advantage of this information and
there's some simplifications along the
way to these component transition
systems further away may be some useful
information about the internal
computation of a particular chunk to get
you know much to get improvements about
the thing here
okay so so we have a paper and we have a
tool so unlike Jamie and Ross I'm not
going to show you my tool but you'll
just have to believe that it's very good
so we actually use two tricks the for
some reason both of them appear to
poeple 2013 so one is about sort of
minimizing automata and one is about
checking NFA equivalence because we use
dynamic programming when we compose when
we construct these these large
transition systems and well this is all
you know we did a big table of
experiments since of course would beat
everything you know it's I have to say I
mean um it's a little bit cheating
because traditionally in this community
of verified Petri Nets you you're given
the global Petri net to start with right
so you're not you're supposed to verify
the global object and we cheat a bit
because we give the decomposition
information that we pre computed
beforehand and actually there's some
there's some really interesting semantic
issues that came up earlier in this
workshop and it was the first time I've
ever heard anyone say this but for
example things like associativity you
know acitivity hold in the mathematical
level but associativity does not hold at
the performance level right so some ways
of associating your your term can be
much quicker than other way way way so
we sort of do all of these things thing
before hand and and then of course the
tool runs on runs very quickly so
there's a whole bunch of papers I should
say that I came Owen Stephens as my PhD
student and he graduated last year and
he wrote a really nice PhD thesis about
this whole idea of um first of all this
composition algebra Petri Nets and also
how you check reach ability and so if
you want sir an overview sort of that
gets him to do it
nitty-gritty and the details Owens
thesis is where to look okay and um and
yet so there's been a bunch of
theoretical work on this and we've also
tried to kind of discuss this with
people from the Petrino community
I think we managed to to make some
headway there okay so so that kind of
was the the first part of the of the
story and so yeah so here we had
compositionality and you know we're able
to verify quickly what comes from our
model checking and I want to tell you
about what happened next
okay so what happened next was one of
the most surprising things that ever
happened to me in my research career so
at some point I sat down I thought okay
I've got this kind of a combinatorial
description of this of these Petri Nets
as string diagrams but can I present it
as a symmetric monaural theory okay so
I've got these these Petri Nets I want
to presented it as a symmetric model
theory and the way I was thinking about
it was that sort of this two ways if you
look at a petri net as a hyper graph
there's two ways that multiplicity comes
in right so first of all a transition
can connect to more than one place right
so you have these transitions that's
sort of for example here this guy this
guy's a synchronization that just says I
want to synchronize all three point
ports in the boundary and it turns out
that when you look at the the way we did
the composition that this guy has a as a
Co unit this guy is just the same guy
reflected and this guy has a unit so in
particular if I just draw them like this
I have a commutative monoid in the
community community of carotenoid
there's also another kind of
multiplicity that comes in with Petri
Nets and that is that a place can
connect to more than one transition so
here I have two separate transitions one
connecting this bit at least two ports
and one connecting these two ports and
then it turns out that this guy also has
has a unit and this guy has a Co unit
and this is just the the the thing
without any transition whatsoever right
because when I compose this guy is just
going to disappear and I'd have the
identity left okay so so here I have
another ma node in the kimono okay so
this this started to the promising so I
thought maybe I can write down all the
equations okay so so first of all
there's this structure here which that's
called let's call it the black structure
so that satisfies the Frobenius
equations in a special law
so far so good and when you look at the
interaction of these two guys
well they satisfied the by algebra
equations which we've seen in a bunch of
talks already so the by algebra
equations essentially tell you that the
monoi demonic of one car distribute
servitude is a homomorphism of the cone
one out of the other car and vice versa
okay so this is looking promising but
then unfortunately the white structure
is not quite Frobenius and I fortune
there's a whole bunch of other
complicated things so I wrote a little
bit about this at kako 2013 but then I
thought okay it's just it's just a
little bit too ugly what if it was just
the most beautiful thing that one could
think of right what if the white was
also Frobenius so he had this black
Frobenius why Frobenius and together
they were they were by more annoyed and
at the same time five years an Aussie
was studying his PhD thesis so I was in
Liang and I and sort of we're talking
about Petri Nets but then we draw these
drew these equations on the board and we
thought what if what is this thing
rights so it's not Petri Nets we know it
but what is it so this is our this is
what we wrote down and we're kind of
thinking what what is this thing
so eventually Fabio visited me in
Southampton when we figured it out and I
was very excited and actually this is a
bit embarrassing I put it on Facebook
right away to give a picture of all the
equations say oh wow this is so nice and
then the next surprisingly acting
happened is that Bob wrote to me on
Facebook saying hey I saw your post
about the graphical calculus this is
actually a fragment of the calculus of
confidential observables Ross Tonkin and
I used in blah blah blah which you've
seen many times during this talk it's
just as EDX calculus alright so if you
take the ZX calculus and you throw out
the phases you essentially get this so
this is all very fascinating
I started off Patriots and suddenly I'm
talking about quantum computing so I was
very confused and excited at the same
time but actually we figured out that
what this guy is is okay so let's call
it IH so the the this is a symmetric
model theory
oh sorry sir I don't so what is this guy
this guy actually is isomorphic to
linear relations over z2 okay so this is
kind of a slightly strange linear
algebraic object and in fact it's part
of a bigger picture that we figured out
that here so let's again this is a kind
of a situation where we have a symmetric
model functor this thing is our
algebraic theory and this thing is this
category of linear relations of the
field of fractions over the rational
numbers okay so this is really crazy
right because we're at the rational
numbers here where the even natural
numbers right it's not it's not very
clear at all so yeah so we figured all
this out and and actually this is should
say that this is now no longer not
merely a functor this is actually out of
some office now so this is a really a
presentation that's an isomorphism of
symmetric one of the categories so this
is a presentation this equation theory
is a presentation of the some category
of linear relations and you get all
kinds of cool things like you know
figuring out that the way we add
fractions is just a special case of the
algebra of diagrams and this other cute
thing that somehow
nothing's stopping you from dividing by
zero and you can sort of figure out
where that leads you so and after all I
mean if you think about what this guy is
you know we have matrices but we also
have kernels and images so if you want
to sort of start doing linear algebra
there's nothing stopping you from doing
linear algebra using string diagrams so
I started a blog about this because I
kind of wanted to popularize the thing I
was very excited at the time and yeah so
there's been some some nice reactions
and social media etc so maybe I should
explain to you what this thing is
because we were trying to figure out how
this whole idea of Frobenius and by
algebra interacting together how we can
understand this in some kind of a
compositional way itself and this came
up during Ross's talk Ross was saying
that one source of compositionality
would be to try to understand the
algebraic theories themselves as
compositional in some sense and I think
one really beautiful example of this and
probably sort of the first paper that
took this point of view was this paper
by Steve Lac titled composing props
so I don't know if I really want to get
into this some into detail of what's
happening here but essentially what's
going on is that this is a cube in which
the top face they're all sort of
syntactic entities right they're all
algebraic theories and at the bottom we
have these kinds of semantics right so
these are the theory this is the theory
of algebra and over some principle ideal
domain and it presents the symmetrical
categorical or matrices over the
principle ideal domain so the
interesting thing is that we can use
this are this framework of distributive
laws introduced by Steve to obtain
equation equation characterizations of
the of the category of coast bands of
matrices and of the category of spans of
matrices so all of these things are some
morphisms right now if I look at the top
face these are algebraic theories so
what happens if i take the push out well
all of these guys share the same
signature so essentially what you do is
you just throw all the equations
together you get you throw in the
equations you get for coast bands and
spans and you get this nice amorphous
appear of linear relations over the
field of fractions of arts so you have
to do a little bit of work down here to
convince yourself that this is a
push-out and the category of props
anyway this is the way we get this kind
of a general story and if you want a
really nice source for understanding how
this works five years and Ozzy's thesis
from last year or so is it's probably
the place to look I'm actually doing
okay so I guess I'm talking very quickly
okay so so that was the kind of a story
about commercial ending algebra which
sort of came out totally by accident
really because you know sometimes you
just kind of follow your nose and think
about what happens if the world was
slightly more beautiful than it really
is
right and linear algebra comes out
okay so I'll tell you about one
application of this thing and this is
about doing signal flow graphs okay so
the signal flow graphs are quite
little-known in control theory and
engineering and they were actually
invented by Claude Shannon in this paper
that nobody knows about called the
theory and design of linear differential
equation machines and I think the reason
why nobody knows about it was it was
classified for quite some time but it's
a very nice paper and the idea is that
that these guys were trying to I don't
know make the canons aim better so they
were constructing circuits from adders
get boxes shaft junctions and shaft and
this whole idea was this this was some
kind of a way of solving you know sets
of of constant some higher order
differential equations
so how do we get to this well this
general picture that I showed you before
it starts off we will be having a
principle ideal domain so one good
source of principle ideal domains is to
start with the polynomial ring okay so
by doing this thing that we had on the
previous slide on the on in the cube we
essentially get a presentation of the
category of linear relations over the
field of polynomial fractions and it's
well known this goes back now to sort of
more than 100 years and combinatorics
people often writes polynomial fractions
as a nice finite syntax for infinite
series all right this is called
generating functions this is your
generating functions and the way you can
understand this is you have a you have a
field embedding from the field of
polynomial fractions to the field of
Laurent series so the Laurent series are
these formal power series that starts at
some finite time in the past and go
possibly infinitely what delegate to
infinity in the future okay so here we
have an isomorphism of categories
embedding us sort of you know having our
syntax means the same thing as linear
relations over polynomial fractions so
because of this field embedding we have
a faithful funk guitar from this
category to this category so overall we
have a syntax for these relations
service over infinite streams okay so
it's almost like like circuit diagrams
that process streams and in fact this is
the case so you can understand the
diagrams in this in this in this world
as an algebra of signal photographs and
sorry this is a typo there should be
buyers so this is another weird thing at
the same time we found out that John
buyers and Jackson there Bailey figured
out what came up with an equivalent
equation presentation so they have a
paper called categories and control and
also Jason's very nice thesis
categories and control apply props which
came out recently so there's other parts
of the story because we've come from a
more computer science background we're
thinking of this as a process are jabrai
so we thought okay we should give this
thing in operational semantics that then
allows us to sort of compute these the
action of these string diagrams step by
step and we had a paper on last year
about this but since I don't really have
much time maybe let me just tell you the
most surprising thing that came out of
this sort of the lesson that I learned
somehow so so the interesting thing
about signal flow graphs is feedback
rights and the Frobenius structure
there's a thing here that gives you the
compact closed structure that allows you
to do feedback now if you look at the
way feedback has been understood over
the last 100 years people kind of look
at this and they they get a bit scared
right because he's there's an input here
there's an output here what does it all
mean rights so people have been coming
up with all kinds of primitive
operations and building mathematical
theories based on them okay so things
like clean East are in computer science
things like trace one little categories
so this is one way of doing it there's
another way of doing it and and somehow
somehow I find I found it really
interesting and rewarding to throw away
the directions on the arrows and just
think and just think about that inputs
and outputs don't exist
okay so just throw away calls out and I
came across this work of a guy called
young villains here's a very influential
control theorist who started something
called the behavioral approach and
control theory and he adds you know a
whole bunch of political papers in which
you said all we should not real science
is we should not use things like inputs
and outputs because they don't really
exist in physical systems I saw a human
that's all human arm you know is a
figment of our imaginations and you know
he's quoting people like like Bertrand
Russell who who wrote things like the
law of causality is
survives like the monarchy I needs
because Sir earnestly supposed to do no
harm but in fact it does okay so we far
away arrowheads we work on compact
clothes categories and unfortunately
this was actually going to be what the
talk was going to be about originally so
I took the description of fit from
Fibonacci's leave a debauchee of the
Fibonacci sequence writes and he
explains it as this this kind of a
rabbit breeding example and actually
Fibonacci's Fibonacci numbers a little
bit different to a Fibonacci numbers
because they start with 1 1 not 0 1 or
not 0 0 1 so this is the generating
function for Fibonacci's Fibonacci
numbers now I didn't explain to you how
the how to do fractions with string
diagrams but when you just take this and
draw it as a string diagram you get you
get this guy ok is a string diagram so
you see this it's kind of confused it
looks like I mean this is not an input
this is not an import so if you actually
think about the flow of inputs and
outputs here it's not really clear
what's going on ok but the interesting
thing is that using the diagrammatic
this using the algebraic theory of the
string diagram so looking this equate
you know the diagram I decreasing the
the equational system that I showed you
I can convert this into something that
looks like this and into something of
the closes ok so they're all equal in
this algebraic theory but there's
something interesting about these two
diagrams you see this diagram I can
understand as input being on the left
and output being on the rights and this
thing is being a feedback loop ok and
with this diagram I can understand this
thing is being an input and an back loop
here so here I have an input here I have
an output here I have an input here I
have an output so the direction of flow
is the opposite but they describe the
same behavior right so as a linear how
much 2 minutes ok I'm almost finished ok
so the interesting thing is by looking
at behavior relationally throwing away
these notions of inputs and outputs I
can you know reorient things and this is
the
verse of the Fibonacci function right so
if it been actually wanted to know what
sequence of killing rabbits and buying
rabbits I have to maintain in order
let's say to keep four rabbits in my
rabbit pen at all times I will just use
this this circuit here alright because
it's deep anyway so okay so my last
slide is so this was kind of an optional
part of the story so I just go for it go
for it very quickly so this is a so in
the beginning God created four Benyus
and by algebra writes and everything
else is just four BS in algebra and
biology by interacting in funny ways
okay so we've seen so many examples in
this workshop well I mean I'll just go
through it very quickly but you know
think we've seen them in quantum we've
seen them and well they've actually
showed up previously in the work of will
go for example we've seen a whole bunch
of them in this talk the stuff in called
Cartesian about categories in which you
see this a lot so somehow for being us
in by algebra is a high-level
programming language for compositional
mathematics and I have some evidence for
what I mean by this and all this
evidence is in this paper from Lix this
year with Brendan Fong and father
episode da in which even though it's
sort of the underlying Maps the mass of
the semantic level is totally different
what we do equation is just we throw
away one equation and replace it with
something slightly weaker and we sort of
convert these string diagrams from the
kinds of semantics that Fabio and
Filippo and I considered to something
that control theorists consider which is
moving away from in streams finite in
the past infinite in the future two
streams that are infinite in both
directions and there's some stuff about
rewriting with dpi so dpi also came up
earlier in this in this workshop but I
think um I don't really have time to to
go into this in detail if you're
interested I can I can talk to you about
it offline thank you very much
questions seem three different versions
of attracting hopf algebra scores
Monica's fans coast pants and inner
relations can you say a little bit about
how their differ in their level of the
presentation yes so I can tell you
exactly how two different yes so it's
all about so this is um the way we get
these presentations is through this
framework of composing props okay so in
particular if you look at this paper
what's the black does is he gets by
monoids from the fear of spans of finite
sets and funk there so spans a finite
set and that happens because when you
take pull backs of finite sets you start
reading off the equations of by algebra
is of by ma nodes from certain small
pullback diagrams okay then you make an
argument that actually if you take these
equations it's enough for everything
right and on the other hand cosine of
finite sets gives you the theory of
special form into algebra and then you
take push outs and you look at
particular push out diagrams and you
read off the equations so we do exactly
the same thing here except were
calculating pull backs and push outs in
the category of matrices and the
categorical matrices has transpose right
so once you know what the limits are you
know what the curl emits are because
everything is you just turn everything
around so essentially what happens is
these two theories you get from one to
the other by changing the colors okay so
changing the colors is is related to the
transpose operation and what happens is
you get something slightly weaker right
so you get special Frobenius structure
on one of the colors but not quite you
get a frigging instruction on the other
and and and a few things like this but
so but they're quite subtly and they're
not very different
everyone ready for lunch break for lunch
I believe you convene at